gemeinsames entspannen im klangbad in
auroville südindien
[Musik]
sie war ja gut aus empfängt
besucherinnen und bewohner im unity
brasilien
[Musik]
dass ein solches will probiert und dass
er sich nicht
[Musik]
die utopie in südindien feiert 50 jahre
eingeladen sind seit 1968 menschen aus
aller welt die den bildern haben ein
leben ohne nation und religion ohne
besitzer und hierarchien zu versuchen
die sengende sonne tamil nadu setzt rot
zu aber sie ist keine die auf gibt seit
37 jahren lebt sie in europa als
mitglied des inneren zirkels steuert sie
diese selbst verwaltete gemeinschaft mit
2700 bewohner mit wer in aue will
arbeitet bezieht ein bescheidenes
grundeinkommen im gratis supermarkt
können die bewohner holen was sie zum
leben brauchen
[Musik]
es gibt kein offizielles pensionsalter
jeder arbeitet solange die hamas
[Gelächter]
es ist eine freude hier zu leben
wir streiten nicht wir bombardieren uns
nicht wir sind auf der suche nach dem
göttlichen bewusst zeit ein wunderbares
leben
das heißt man das wenn sich bringe so
wie es heißt du auf dein er
gemeinschaftlich und damit als erste
sondern wird als beteiligung als
passiert so konnte burschen aber wir
sollten sehr als wär was mitnimmt wird
registriert
ein leben ohne geld das war die vision
der gründerin von eur will
miral wasser das porträt der mutter wie
sie genannt wird ist allgegenwärtig
hier verliebte sich ruth in einen
holländer der damals in einer kleinen
hütte lebte er wurde der vater ihrer
beiden kinder heute ist sie allein dass
sie entschlossen war ihr leben einer
utopie zu widmen forderte ihre eltern
heraus
er war auf der suche nach einem anderen
leben als sie mit 22 erstmals nach
indien reiste auch weil sie sich vom
vater unterdrückt fügte dieses haus
selber zu bauen wir stärker als auf oder
hey ich das sicher 67 batterie mix auch
durchaus mit und du bist nicht um dass
der schnitt und mit 25 zog die lehrerin
von chur nach auch wenn bosch täglich
aus der wüste wuchs hier das neue der
versuch eine überzeugung in die tat
umzusetzen gefiel ihr
sie half mit beim bau der iss matri man
dir des meditations- zentrums und beim
aufforsten des abgeholzten landes eine
hippie community wird das beschrieben
die das hielt die gemeinschaft
bezeichnet wird sehen händler auch viele
kabarettisten raucher und einfach alles
vom vater der kinder als sie sich früh
getrennt
die kinder hatten viel freiheit und
spielkameraden aus aller welt tochter
ladiner lebt heute wieder zeitweise in
au vin
sie hat in der schweiz seine lehre als
groß gemacht mit dem geld der eltern
baute ruht ein großzügiges haus nicht
nur für sich sondern für die
gemeinschaft denn in euro will gibt es
nur ein wohnrecht immobilien kann man
nicht besitzen oder diener war die
schweiz ein kulturschock wirklichen
dunkler und werk sieben personen eine
rezente war es ziemlich viel aber
klarheit und für mich ist dass ich
wirklich ziemlich depressiv geworden und
bin wirklich nicht gewusst wie so viele
sachen einfach nicht verstanden wie man
irgendwie halt einfach so einfache
sachen auf der post ska wie alles
funktioniert will adina bin auch gut
manchmal in der schweiz arbeiten heute
hat sie dank einem erbe mehr finanzielle
unabhängigkeit mit dem grundeinkommen
liegen keine extras trennen
gleich nebenan wohnt latinas bruder
kevin er spricht nur englisch
die gemeinsame sprache eur vj
[Musik]
ich liebe es hier natürlich auch
deswegen weil es mein zuhause ist
aber ich war draußen ich weiß wie der
rest im moment ist hat schon nachteile
besonders weil wir so klein ist
da ist für junge leute nicht viel los
darum gehen auch viele junge raus um zu
studieren de ist es eine ideale welt
nicht wirklich eine ideale welt würde
ich sagen es gibt noch viel zu tun
vor allem sind wir hier in indien da
bist du mit vielen fast noch stärker
konfrontiert als in europa weil indien
so schnell gewachsen ist so viele leute
rat sieht man die negativen seiten der
konsumgesellschaft deutlich die
mangelnde sorge für den planeten
kevin fühlt sich wohl in der utopie was
ladiner betrifft macht sich die mutter
mehr gedanken
[Musik]
zur vorwoche umständen dann sage ich ja
ja ja ja was ich mache das was ich höre
wenn du hast du meine spiel musste klare
wende schweiz von hanni wenig seite
überhaupt nicht kollektiv respekt haben
vor steckt redet über das mediendorf wo
wir viel soziale projekt auch gemacht
werden nun die zum thalia mitgemacht
haben und denn wenn amerika das klima
bestimmt
natürlich ist es wichtig vor dem projekt
das als experiment neue woods immer
lieber als gemeinschaft ohne hierarchien
leben hier im rathaus von auo will
arbeitet seit vielen jahren im inneren
rat mit dem city council
es herrscht basisdemokratie das heißt es
wird endlos diskutiert
die sitzungen dürfen wir nicht filmen
weil nicht alle damit einverstanden sind
ein blick ins finanz büro zeigt dass das
ideal der multikulturellen gesellschaft
lebt ungelöst aber ist in der geld losen
utopie das thema geld intransparenz
begünstigt eigennutz und konflikte gut
arbeitet mit an lösungen den egoismus
versus kollektiv also ja wir lernen wir
wirklich und den kramer hat es ist wenn
er alle magath das ist mir den augen an
geld für wohnraum und land mangelt es
euro will konnte längst noch nicht alles
land kaufen vom stadtmodell in form
eines spiralen hebels ist man noch
galaxien weit entfernt
roth sohn kevin ist bauunternehmer das
dilemma bringt er auf den punkt du
kannst nicht hier leben und arbeiten und
genug verdienen um die ein haus zu
kaufen
das geld muss von woanders kommen
entweder du gehst raus und geld zu
verdienen wurde die gründe ist eine
firma aber das braucht zeit bis du
etabliert ist mit seiner firma verdient
er außerhalb auch ums geld
der gewinn macht sollte mindestens ein
drittel davon der gemeinschaft abgeben
für solche wohnungen haben junge leute
zu wenig geld
euro will ist jedoch dringend auf junge
zuwanderer angewiesen denn die pioniere
von einst kommen ins alter doch für
junge ist geld eine hürde
wer nach euro will ziehen möchte muss im
ersten jahr 12.000 dollar bezahlen
deshalb hat erwin nun aufträge für junge
zuwanderer kostenlose unterkünfte zu
bauen
er zeigt uns ein solches projekt das er
vor kurzem fertiggestellt hat
das ist für neuankömmlinge es ist
temporär ist so dass du wenigstens etwas
einfaches haus zu machen
euro wird immer noch eine große
anziehungskraft für menschen die dinge
ausprobieren wollen
hier zeigt ein fachmann interessierten
wie man mit einfachsten mitteln ein
erdhaus baut kelvin lernte so von
anderen leuten aber auch viel von seinem
vater einem schreiner wenn die arbeit in
der werkstatt ruth sowie jetzt
meditierte oft und befasst sich mit der
philosophie die hinter auch wilstedt
wenn du hier aufwächst dann ist alles
selbstverständlich als kind war das für
mich etwas dass die oldies taten oder
lassen
aber so langsam wenn du älter wirst dann
realisierst du dass da etwas
dahintersteckt
es sind nicht einfach deine eltern auf
irgendeinem tritt es sind werte die
fängst selber an zu entdecken worum es
geht
[Musik]
für dich ist es also mehr als ein
abenteuerspielplatz
sicher es ist nicht gerade der ort an
dem du sein willst wenn du unterhaltung
suchst
[Musik]
das wahrzeichen und die seele von eur
will ich das material an der die große
meditationsraum es steht für die suche
nach dem göttlichen bewusstsein
unabhängig von religion persönliche
entwicklung ist das ziel ein neuer
mensch ohne gier und ohne angst
[Musik]
robinho ein indischer freiheitskämpfer
und philosoph ist der geistige vater von
eur will um die ideen euro windows in
die tat umzusetzen gründete seine
spirituelle wege fährt den 1968 euro
will mehr als wasser genannt mutter
starb 1973 bis heute ist sie der kompass
für die utopie immer mehr ausflügler aus
der nahen stadt pondicherry entdecken
die grüne oase mit internationalem flair
zieht touristen an aber auch spekulanten
geld sammeln für den landkauf ist
wichtiger denn je damit auch will den
boden unter den füßen nicht verliert und
alles was mehr investierten wo natürlich
auch interessantes verlegt wo gern vor
dem profitieren möchten und hotel bauen
oder weiß er setzte auch will früher
eher auf abschottung versucht man nun
die tamilischen dörfer einzubeziehen
zuwanderer beruht werden als fremde
wahrgenommen
doch die tamilischen eurovia na gut 40
prozent der bewohner wirken als
vermittler
sie setzen dabei auf die global
vernetzte gut ausgebildete jugend
ich sage immer meine kinder werden einen
großen unterschied machen
es wird sich verändern es wird viel
besser sein als heute
es war schon bald in 45 jahren
dann werden wir alle das spiel gemeinsam
spiel nicht nur indien alles verändert
sich das weiß niemand besser als
frederik einer der pioniere
er kannte die gründerin euro will's noch
persönlich heute ist das abenteuer für
ihn ein ganz anderes als vor 50 jahren
jede organisation die 50 jahre alt wird
hatte denn tendenz zu verkosten zu
erstarren ein system zu werden
du guckst mir nicht mehr in die augen
sollte schreibt mir doch eine e mail
und du bist du lebst ja gar nicht mich
da gar nicht auf unsere liste führung
geführt
das gab es damals das war so ein
bisschen wenn man sagt john wayne
wir waren aus der ranger zeit keine
keine zäune kein garnichts die freie
prärie und jetzt sind halt viele zäune
da muss ich mich so ein bisschen drauf
neueinstellungen das ist ein abenteuer
für mich um da nicht zynisch zu werden
um da nicht in der vergangenheit hängen
zu bleiben
damals wie wir gekommen sind mal hörte
ständig ich finde dann wie man sagt
mutter sagte einer der botschaften
remane young never stops trading tools
perfekt
und was ist rumänien don't get stuck in
the past the step forward
hindu priester weihen eine neue straße
ein
die indische sponsoren finanziert haben
und sieht das skeptisch ähnliche rama
machen und dass die nachbarn jedoch kurz
danach gelang das projekt und das wie
ist das projekt nicht irgendwer
religiöse unternehmen
die schweizerin fühlt sich in der
gemeinschaft aufgehoben
aber manchmal sieht sie dunkle wolken
aufziehen
in der sehr aggressiven umwelt und auch
wir hin mit denen großes problem für
schmutzig
also auf also ich sage das jetzt einfach
so ich bin für ein taxi das land also
wirklich an starken auf dem herz regiert
worden ist und hilflos durch der
kapitalismus ist im land sieht ich habe
dann mit romina kollegin gerda oder was
jetzt das sagen aber das stimmt zu dass
sie immer wieder denkt eine schoko tanja
schmitz und passwort
auch wenn ich nicht wenn ja dann blieben
möchte misst ganze hätten auch in den
haag über den und den experimenten eine
absage
[Musik]
37 jahre ihres lebens hat sie für die
utopie eines anderen lebens gearbeitet
und gelebt
[Musik]
die welt scheint heute von den idealen
euro will es weiter weg denn je
doch ruth lässt das nicht gelten max hat
ja in der welt auf vielzahl funk urlaubs
und maxi gleichzeitig auch die überall
auf der welt wo auch genauso wie mir
schaffen einfach vielleicht in kleinere
gruppen oder oder durch doch ganz viele
media und sache also wenn man lockt in
staates subkultur und darum denke dass
das experiment auch wer liebt auch nach
50 jahren
doch die verwirklichung der utopie
braucht vermutlich etwas länger weil ich
damals weltweiten der roboter wurden mit
hätten wir das vielleicht schneller
gegangen werden wir sind bestimmt hof
ein extralob
[Gelächter]
[Musik]